we will incentivize democratic behavior
but we will not promote democracy
through costly military interventions
or by attempting to overthrow
authoritarian regimes by force
we've tried these tactics in the past
however well-intentioned
they haven't worked quite an interesting
use of words but the pattern from the
united states of intervening in the
affairs of other countries destabilizing
and overthrowing governments around the
world is
quite well known one looks at the
history of iraq of libya
afghanistan one looks throughout south
and central america one can see many
examples of the united states
intervening in other countries affairs
destabilizing and overthrowing
governments
in fact in recent years we've heard many
calls from u.s leaders for governments
around the world to be overthrown and
for leaders
to step down assad needs to go we will
continue to work
with our partners in the international
community to press
gaddafi to leave the time has come for
nicholas maduro to go
what's interesting is that just a day
ago we actually had a tweet from anthony
blinken
in which he gave full support to juan
gueto
juan gueto is an individual in venezuela
who has proclaimed himself to be the
president
and has been engaging in violent
attempts to destabilize venezuela
to overthrow the elected government
there have even been
u.s military contractors that have been
involved in those military coup attempts
so
having anthony blinken uh you know you
know voicing support for juan guedo the
unelected individual who claims to be
venezuela's leader kind of flies in the
face of his claim that the united states
won't be using force
now there was one loophole you could say
in anthony blinken's remarks he did
create a pretext in which the united
states would be continuing to use force
against governments
of course we will never hesitate to use
force
when american lives and vital interests
are at stake
now what exactly would constitute such a
threat he did not
lay out any specific criteria so it
seems that though the united states
through its new secretary of state is
announcing that no more force will be
used
many wonder if this will simply be a
changing of rhetoric
it looks like the united states will
most likely be continuing
its foreign policy activities but only
time will tell
and he did leave that huge loophole
where he said vital interests
vital interests can mean almost anything
mars the moon you name it it could be a
vital interest to america
if a politician wants to say that's the
case you know trump
certainly had his own style that was
very bombastic
and out there and other presidents have
been more
reserved in their in their description
of activities but when you look at the
actual policies
we've seen no change and and i think it
sounds like rhetoric not something that
we can count on yet
you know president trump started a trade
war with china
and now president biden's talking about
well we're going to cooperate with other
countries but we're also going to have
trade agreements that protect our
workers and do this and that
which in the end probably means the
exact same policies as an actual trade
war
so i don't see biden tearing up
a lot that is substantial i see him
rebranding a lot of the same old thing